qu'il y ait des débats entre nous c'est
normal c'est le propre de la démocratie
et on n'est pas des playmobil comme
certains voulaient nous nous nous
présentait donc on a des débats entre
nous et ensuite il ya une quelque chose
qui s'appelle le fait de trancher et
donc en l'occurrence c'est la première
ministre et président de la république
qui tranche un certain nombre de
dispositifs et la majorité soutient
l'action du gouvernement donc je pense
que nous devons avoir des débats nous
devons faire en sorte de avoir un
intérêt qui est celui des français celui
de la transition écologique et je pense
que nous trouverons des accords à la
magie pour dans la majorité mais aussi
ensuite avec les oppositions
[Musique]